helping out organizations that do so
much good in the community tomorrow is
our next star media group's Founders Day
of caring yeah we're hoping you the
viewers will help bring in items for the
local non-profits that we're supporting
tomorrow 8 news now reporter Lauren
negretti is live at Helping Hands of
Vegas Valley serving seniors with many
needs in our community Lauren good
morning tell us more
good morning yes Helping Hands in Vegas
Valley does so much you guys and as far
as our help out here they need they're
requesting non-perishable food items to
stock things like this glorious Pantry
right here around me to talk more about
it here I'm joined by Courtney hum So
Courtney what are the overarching
programs of Helping Hands of Vegas
Valley so we have Pantry minor home
repair respite care transportation and a
nutrition program thank you for that and
so some of the ways volunteers can have
can help out come shopping for seniors
what are some ways volunteers can help
out so we they can help out in our
walk-in Pantry they can help out in the
warehouse delivering food to senior or
homebound seniors we also have admin
volunteers but we can also use donations
both monetary and kind and of course
volunteering is very very vital to our
organization and how do people sign up
to volunteer hhovv.org
and what's something else here that you
can say is so special about you know
Helping Hands in Vegas Valley you know
you guys were highlighted here for our
annual Founders Day
um we just really want to make sure that
people know about our programs um just
getting the word out and making sure
that everybody has access because there
are no costs to the seniors and 16 above
and we just really want to make sure
that everybody that needs help can get
help definitely from food to
transportation to some tech help to some
respite care for caretakers yes a lot of
things going on over here yes thank you
so so much thank you for having us thank
you and so again non-perishable items
for Anita over here we have two other
organizations project Maryland
requesting feminine hygiene products and
hope link requesting some money we've
got those links on how to donate on our
website 8newsnow.com for now live over
here at Helping Hands of Vegas Valley
Lauren negretti 8 news now we do
incredible work Lauren thank you so much
for that